a single pellet can safely store several  hundred meters of a lightweight cable  [Music]  [Music]  attention all units in the confines of  precinct 13 receiving a 1030 on West  19th Street and Broadway assailant is  Caucasian male mid-30s 170 to 180 pounds  shoulder-length blond hair last seen on  foot heading eastbound on 19th Street  [Music]  [Music]  got a description well no he was math  mask and most of his victims are  suspects I love them with serious rap  sheets are calling him a vigilant okay  he's not a vigilante  [Music]  [Music]  and spandex  everything stand extraordinary velocity  vector is a function of both mass and  acceleration oh come on you know better  than anyone the weight of the bobbin any  pendulum has no effect on swing see it  doesn't affect frequency but it's  totally it's actually momentum  [Music]  [Music]  hey MA yes eggs organic got it  you